hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are continuing
our coverage with the match England
versus Maxie Marshall and Rob but I'm
only going to show the Armageddon game
as all the four games between the two of
them I have ended in a draw it was a lot
of fighting but and you know who could
have gone either way
yeah but like I said in the end all of
them ended in a draw which resulted in
this well unexplainable game I mean you
could explain it of course but it's just
it's just amazing well better to just
show it to you guys so dink with the
white pieces open the width d4 and
Maxime goes for d5 so not going for any
of his room filled ideas we have c4 and
now c6 we have the Slav defense Knight
to f3 and now Knight to f6 we have
Knight to c3 and here Maxime tries to
surprise ding with this very old the
continuation Bishop to f5 which is kind
of kind of a kind of a cheating in chess
since you want a developer light square
bishop before closing the pawn structure
here so you don't have to worry about
developing it later as developing the
light square bishop is one of the main
problems and black will face however
ding is well versed in well even in
lines that are no longer played so si
captures on d5 but now Nazi characters
instead Maxine goes for Knight
characters so really really trying to
trick him there we have Queen to b3 by
being immediately challenging the b7
pawn and now Queen to b6 just defending
so you might think okay so we're not
just gonna trade nice straight Queens
and we're gonna go into a nice endgame
well not not exactly here bingos for
Knight characters on d5 and while you
could trade Queens here maybe right away
then White has this in between Knights
e7 check and after the King attacks it
then you of course recapture character
and maybe you help white develop a
little bit if you allow him to get this
check in or nothing serious however
after this nightcap force on d5 Maxime
goes forward with the main line of this
line which is to give up the pawn here
Queen captures on d5 and now just kicks
away the queen with e6 and now black
will have a lot of pressure
slide bishop slices over this way this
one will come over here 96th night
before well all sorts of ideas are
possible now and you have to be very
careful with your queen but being fairly
instantly played Queen back to b3
he grabbed a pawn and now he doesn't
mind trading as if he trades then he
will get the semi open the file for his
rook and he's again very happy although
this is Armageddon so ding has 5 minutes
Maxime has 4 and ding has to win this
game this game so Maxime continues with
Knight to c6 and here just III biding
opening up the light square bishop and
now there is one game in the database
were nice the b4 was played but here
sorry there is one game where Bishop to
b4 check was played right away but here
Maxime goes for nice to b4 and it's it's
as if it's as if Maxime is the one who
has to win this game in order to win the
match it's really really just crazy
stuff so threatening night to see to
check to win some material here but ding
replies again almost instantly Queen a4
check now forcing the King - well the
choose between it either be 8 or 7 or to
go back with the night and if you go
back with the night and white continues
normal development Bishop to b5 and so
on so here
Maxime played Kings to d8 however King
to e7 is a better Square for the King it
looks unnatural because you block around
on dark square Bishop but as you'll see
it is needed so King to d8 by Maxine and
now Dean just goes Bishop to d2 like
there's no threat here like knife the CT
doesn't exist so Maxine goes for it
Knight the CT with check and King goes
for King to e2 and we reach the position
from the thumbnail and he says that ok
you got nothing here and indeed you
really you really don't have anything
here for example if you go for the night
now the problem of King being Gandhi 8
instead of on e7 is this Bishop to a5
and you would win the black queen so
instead after this King to eat you move
maxime tried Queen captures on b2 now
going after the rook with the Queen but
now ding just goes for Knight to e5 the
absolute strongest move in the position
threatening Queen to d7 mate and well
it's not all that easy too
the defend here there's no way to defend
here unless you try you try something
like Maxine tried b5 so ok now you've
stopped made but now Queen to a5 with
check from dink King t8 and now comes
Queen to c7 and it was in this position
unmoved 16 that Maxine washer lagravis I
in the game and the match was the
Dingley ran as he won in Armageddon so
he doesn't get the full three points he
gets the two points but still and Maxine
gets one point but still this is a one
of the craziest games I've seen in a
while and I'm pretty sure one of the
worst losses of Maxine's career but ok
it's blitz oh you know who cares really
but yeah here you resigned as Queen
Queen to d7 will be checkmate if you
block it then Queen the f7 is made you
the roadblock that the d8 square and on
the other hand if you try something like
Bishop e7 to make some room for the king
then it's just Queen c6 check you're
gonna pick up this guy so if King here
just Queen to d7 is mate and if you move
the king then just Queen captures with
check butcher blocks and Queen captures
with mate so yeah after Queen to c7
maxime resigned and like I said the
magic of studying leerin and we are
continuing with our match of the other
pair Yanni Pompey vs. onigiri as well
this was quite a game your friends at
the bar in the library are really going
to enjoy this one you know if it ever
opens up again which I'm sure it will
but they're really just the incredible
stuff I'm sure that Maxine tried to
throw leading off guard with that
Slava Bishop the 5 idea fall by knife
capture Sun d5 but in the end it was a
ding who knew everything about that line
and the maxime just you know just rushed
into his own demise basically so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
pretty sure Maxim Maxim did and I would
like to thank camera and Ellis
Enterprises Yarbrough
our Tom Stewart Steven Wentworth and
tony moore the guitar for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos Aaron thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational until it finishes so thank
you all I will see you soon and have a
rest of your day